fresh off a world tour and his debut
Netflix special Matt R's popularity is
at an all-time high but ever since
natural selection came out on November
14th a portion of his fans have
completely turned on Matt R attempting
to cancel the comedian for jokes made
about domestic abuse during his standup
comedy special how do you describe this
hum is is there a definition or a label
for the kind of humor that you just say
the worst possible scenario it's funny
because it's ridiculous because you know
it's not true because you know it's not
what you mean you know it's not the
right thing that is what makes it funny
what is that style of Comedy kind of
irony it's a kind of ir irony it's not
not fully sarcasm it's not totally
satire but it's a wildly common sense of
humor this is what comedians had to say
about the recent Matt R outrage can you
believe how much trouble he got in for
that oh yeah well um it's not look the
joke is whatever it's not a strong joke
but it's also just people are looking
right right yes when when you rise like
this especially and you look like that
he cares about comedy I get it he
probably works hard on his act but it's
not the strongest you know punch lines
you're going to find in the [__] so
it's like people are just trying to take
it you know they're looking for
something and it's like whenever you do
a joke that is that subject matter this
is my thing about Freedom whenever this
comes up with freedom of speech in
general with comedy it's like it's not
that you're not allowed to say something
you have to make it good if you're going
to do something hard
you're taking one of these like open
micers that want to say the NW it's
you're not almost no one should no I
like I'm not going to say never because
it's just like I'm you know
philosophically opposed to saying you
can never say something but almost no
one should almost no white person should
say you know unless it's a really [__]
it's got unless really racist you should
everyone's going after Matt R now and
now there's articles about okay but was
it was it everyone or is it like no well
now there's articles and well they're
always going to write an articles
Marin's got a thing where he's like this
guy [__] sucks like Marin's having
the comment on the state of comedy and
this guy and it's like did he do
anything other than made a joke yeah no
he didn't do anything wrong well people
aren't mad at the comedy even they're
like it sucks a l honestly I don't even
know his standup at all the [__] that
I've seen that he's done has been fine
it's not like it's not I might do him I
might do something with him yeah but why
why do people hate to a movie We're
trying to like a buddy cop it's me and
him no I'm dead serious well I think
he's great about way this is kind of
like loow hanging fruit cuz the the the
fact that he can generate all that money
is a testament that he is like making
the hamster wheel and to go after the
hamster wheel is like that's not it's
like uh no but I'm saying like for
example with the with the Taylor Swift
thing M does she this woman get hurt if
five people in the world say she's not
great no everyone I've ever met says
she's phenomenal so people are really
upset with his opening joke so um he's
talking about how he he and his friend
went to a ratchet Baltimore restaurant
and they realized their server had a
black eye so here we'll listen to audio
to that one real quick yeah there and
the hostess who like seats you at the
restaurant had a black
eye a full black ey and it wasn't like
what happened it was pretty obvious what
happened and we couldn't get over the
fact that we're like this is the face of
the company like this is this is who you
have greeting people and my boy who I
was with was like yeah I feel bad for
her man I feel like they should you know
put her in the kitchen or something
where nobody nobody has to see her face
you know and I was like yeah but I feel
like if she could cook she wouldn't have
that black
eye no problems with the jokes that go
right to the edge there yeah I know so
uh people are really upset about it
online and um so and he's actually
received a ton of backlash now he's a
really popular comedian especially with
the ladies so um so yeah he's getting a
lot of backlash so he goes on Instagram
to apologize he puts up a story says hey
um if you've ever been offended by by
joke I've told here's a link to my
official apology and you click the link
and it takes you to this page here it's
a special needs
helmets now I like him there you go just
I now I like him it's only good for the
special right backlash is great I mean
that's what you want then defensive
jokes people like what what are we
talking about here yeah yeah so and yeah
we can always appreciate the doubling
down did you hear the crowd laugh I did
I I I like the not apologizing part
nobody thinks domestic violence well
nobody who isn't a scumbag thinks
domestic violence is funny however that
doesn't mean you can't make funny
domestic violence jokes is the joke
funny we you can all pretend to be
incredibly and clutch your pearls but
every one of you have have laughed and I
don't know if it makes you feel better
because your friend told you the joke or
you laughed behind closed doors but
every one of you have laughed at had a
joke that you would not tell in public
you are allowed to decide for yourself
what is acceptable but what was a clear
indication that there's no line is that
there were more domestic violence
survivors saying I didn't mind the joke
or we have to learn to laugh that's how
we heal or there were some who were like
hey I don't mind the the domestic
violence jokes I just didn't think that
one was funny yeah by the way nobody's
saying you have to think Matt's funny or
any of us M but it's art some people
would have been mad if it was the best
joke of all time sure but then half of
people wouldn't have and so the fact
that it's he gets people that both want
to come at him for comedy reasons and
for like tattletale you shouldn't say
that reasons and together that's a very
powerful force like comedy nerds and
like
tattletales together a lot a lot of
ladies who didn't love comedy maybe who
just like his face I think that's the
thing it's like he brought in a lot of
people who maybe weren't comedy
fans and now they're just like we didn't
sign up for that and we were like well
we do that stuff all the time I know I
don't talk about the jokes we beat women
all the time no but uh like when you get
that big you just are going to get
people popping in yeah but it's also an
opening joke that's
structurally like we you it's like start
with something soft well that's start
with something like you know what I mean
yeah I agree but that's why people think
he did it on purpose that's like a big
Theory what that he did purpose to just
kind of shed those ladies and show like
I'm a I'm an edgy guy now that I'll get
dragged online I'll get some Buzz we
were talking about this on patreon a bit
but like your your fans don't have the
time to like really like invest and
understand you for who you are so
anything that kind of goes against their
perception of you because again they
don't really know who you are just yet
they're quick to react to and be like
hey this isn't the version of you that I
thought you were whereas like your fans
fans that have been listening to you for
what the last 10 years you've been doing
content you could say pretty much any
[__] up thing and they'll be like I
know who a is I've been listening to a 8
hours a week so I think what happens
with with Matt is he's in a situation
where there's so many people watching
him that don't really know him and then
it's very easy to get a convoluted idea
of who he is and there's a lot of people
that I'm sure are looking at him and
going [__] that guy for being so famous
remember when you get really successful
people want to tear you down that's just
human instinct I also knew him from
wilding out and he's he's a sweet he's a
kid I mean to me he's 27 now but he's oh
he's a sweet he's like a a nice person
he's I saw him do a few interview his CR
is it was kind of hilarious because I
saw him with um my man um Dave poror
from bar stol and he was like he said
something that I've heard in rap before
from like Dave and a few other people
they like his perceived attractiveness
hurts his comedy you know dve one said
that and people laughing about like
[__] you just can't rap my [__]
like what do you think you look too good
to rap like you know what I mean you
know he made a like I was listening to
to his ideas about it compelling thing
it was like Hey listen when you're a a
comedian usually it's your words that is
you know making people enamored about
what the [__] they're into it with you
he would have these shows where a woman
would just show up just to be like yo he
looks amazing your skill always has to
exceed whatever else you bring you were
a cute kid you probably boy friendly
ohey boy handsome boy pretty uh little
fian slip boyf friendly boy friendly
it's all that PO out New Guinea talk
it's [__] you had those soft lips
I've seen that little pick of you with
the [__] earring earring in the
leather jacket that's not good for
comedy though I'm funnier being ugly def
yeah for sure yeah when you get older
you're funnier it's it's like like Matt
R he takes a lot of [__] cuz he's too
beautiful yeah tough yeah tall handsome
perfect hair mhm you know too Squidward
the handsome Squidward jaw people [__]
on him for zero reason being sexy if he
was a little guy with glasses doing the
same act no one would be mad at him yeah
but he also Pro he wouldn't get as much
attention though that's the that's the
double- Ed sword right is like a bunch
of like you know horny women aren't
coming out to fck true to a nebbishy to
to 20-year-old Ari that you met with
Matt R's act he's not selling out
[__] Arenas that is true he's got
that going for him like the audience is
like half mils totally would it's a mil
thing I might put it over half lot like
these older ladies yeah yeah like this
one girl this is a clip that we got sent
this morning this one girl made a
comment about how Matt R went at my
six-year-old son who's Autistic or
something and how dare he and on the
surface you're like yo what the [__] is
that what happened is this kid had a he
had some response to a Matt R joke Matt
R said something about the planets that
was inaccurate this an astrology joke
and the punchline is about Rings
basically and it's a joke about
astrology and this kid loves outer space
so he corrects Matt R in the video and
then goes also you are mean to women and
then Matt R responds to the Tik Tok and
this is all on the surface saying like
hey buddy Santa Claus isn't real your
mom makes money on only fans something
else that's over the line he says your
mom buys you your presence using only
fans money oh there it is funny over the
line a little bit because it's a kid and
everybody's going to jump on but and
everybody's overlooking is this woman
posted that video on her own personal
page it's not the kid making a Tik Tok
on his page saying hey Matt R you so and
so this girl who makes a living on Tik
Tok so she says on social media so she
says is using her kid to make content
right and then Matt R gets which is her
dream Matt R gets telling her kid what
to say too the kid doesn't know oh yeah
you think the kid knows Matt R is mean
to women at 6 years old he's actually
six she says six yeah yeah I mean 2.2
million Tik Tok followers also wow and
so now she's just like now that he
responded that's her dream scenario her
dream scenario is Matt R is really mean
to my kid and nobody's talking about
that part all these people who are just
kind of like hoping to antagonize this
guy this man to get him to respond so
they can make money it's like yo y'all
are just as [__] and nobody's talking
about you especially this girl who's
pimping her kid out like that like you
want your kid to get told Santa's not
real by some [__] 27-year-old yeah
why does get some views why does a
six-year-old have Tik Tok in the first
place like that seems crazy it's not his
Tik Tok it's on her page but she still
has him do a video and then this whole
thing she does I don't protect my kids's
identity I don't pimp I don't use them
for videos it's a video you posted on
your page I just again I think
everybody's in a real hurry to get on to
this kid because he's a good-look white
man who got really successful really
quickly he'll be fine yeah he's going to
be fine he's it's also people you don't
get that white hot without cooling off a
little bit for a minute but like yeah
he's I think he'll be fine I don't but
if he had just had if he just had not
done that special yeah I don't know not
that special he just not done that joke
I think I don't maybe there probably
would be less Buzz about the special
that was that's the theory butel theory
about the stuff like like that's the
thing about I will give him Credit in
that it feels similar to those where
it's like everybody's talking about it
is everybody saying it's the best
special they've ever seen in their lives
no but from a pure number standpoint
everyone is talking about it can't argue
with the I but I did watch a few of the
because I'm like well I want to see how
angry these ladies are and what's fing
to me is they'll be like well I like the
guy now I I hate him cuz he condones
violence against women you're like whoa
condones it's a joke about violence SWS
with where'd you get the condoning thing
but it goes exactly but it goes to
stav's Theory like the jokes when you go
there they have to be home runs right
right right and that's why you know uh I
mean that's why people get in trouble
normally from podcasts when like talking
structured but when when you bring that
in a special you want you and you go
there you want to be yeah an an a joke
so you're [__] round ey that whole
thing that's going to come back to Haun
you this whole idea that you just want
to remove like straight white males need
to be removed from entertainment no no
no you don't remove them from
entertainment you just add other things
but this move they have is be like you
know this toxic masculinity nonsense and
all this kind of let's just remove these
people so because everybody wants to
watch this other stuff no they don't
like nobody wanted to see the WNBA
Marvel movie that just came out first of
all did you have any guilt about the
domestic violence joke which by the way
I also thought was very funny cuz it's a
completely madeup story if you want to
learn even more about this Matt R
situation our entire in-depth breakdown
will be on the end screen right after
this at joke
world that's did it joke
world and the world is
wrld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke world check it out